Google Veil 3 has completely changed the
AI filmmaking game with its ability to
create cinematic AI videos along with
realistic sound effects and character
voices all inside one platform. This
will be the last time you fail me. I
know it's frustrating to watch tutorials
which show clips of highquality videos,
but when you go and try to create the AI
videos yourself, you get lower quality
clips like this one that look like
PowerPoint slides. That's why I made
this video specifically for people like
you who want the real advice. Not just a
surface level explanation, but a deep
dive into practical tips that will
actually help you with your AI films.
May the force be with you.
Google Veil 3 is accessed through Flow,
which is Google's new film making
platform. So, let's go ahead and launch
it. Once we're inside, we can see a list
of our past projects. I'll go ahead and
create a new project right now. From
here, we can start creating our AI
videos. There's a couple different
options. Text to video, frames to video,
ingredients to video. We're going to
cover all of them, but let's start with
text to video where we'll just enter a
prompt and it'll create a video for us.
What's new in Google Veil 3 is the
ability to directly generate talking
characters. So, I'll create a video of a
Jedi from a Star Wars movie. I'm going
to describe the appearance a little bit.
She has green skin, these geometric
tattoos across her face. Um, also give
her a yellow lightsaber, and we're going
to tell her to talk about how to use the
force inside this AI video. Let's go
ahead and generate
that. When you're generating the video,
you need to make sure you've actually
selected the newest Google Vo3 model. If
we go to the settings tab right here,
you can change the number of outputs per
prompt. I've set that to one to generate
one video at a time. But down here in
the quality, make sure you've selected
the highest quality with experimental
audio. That's the newest Veil 3 model.
The fast and quality options default to
the older Veil True model, so you won't
get the best looking videos if you use
these. Here's what the video turned out
to look like. The Force is a subtle
energy. You have to feel it, not just
see it. What's impressive about this is
that it animates a talking speaking
character just from a text prop. And the
quality of the lip sync and the emotions
in the video are very high. We can also
make the AI say specific words from a
script if we want. I'm using the same
prompt of a female Jedi from Star Wars
with green skin. I've described her
appearance a little bit closer. So this
time I also told her the specific
clothing to wear, which is a lightweight
brown and gold robe. And she's also
meditating inside a quiet swamp
illuminated by bol luminescent plants on
an alien world. This time I'm
specifically prompting for her to say,
"The force doesn't scream, it hums.
Listen and you'll know which path is
open." The force doesn't scream, it
hums. Listen and you'll know which path
is open. Look at the way the hand
motions are joined together with the
speech and the facial expressions and
the wrinkles on the face all go together
very very well. Now I want to go a
little more in depth on this. How much
control do we have over the voices? Can
we actually change the way the
character's voice sound? So I rewrote
this prompt. This time I told her to
have a highpitched and nasal voice which
should sound like she kind of has a
stuffy nose a little bit. So then if we
generate the
video, here's what that character sounds
like. The force doesn't scream, it
hums. Listen and you'll know which path
is open. It's a great looking video, but
it didn't actually follow my prompt of
giving it a high-pitched and nasal tone
to her voice. The way Google Video3
generates the voices is dependent on the
way that the characters look. I
generated a video of a Sith. He's an
older weathered man. And if we listen to
his voice, it's going to have a deeper,
grittier tone to it. Pain is not
punishment. It is
revelation. Feel it and you will
understand me. Depending on the video of
the character that you're generating,
Veil 3 will match the voice to the way
that character looks.
Target acquired. Regret will be brief.
But unfortunately, there isn't a way to
actually change the way the character
sounds inside the prompt. This might not
seem like a huge problem, but sometimes
it does generate voices that don't match
the way the characters look at all.
Luke, I am your father. But sticking
with the theme of characters, can we
actually generate videos of the same
character inside different scenes? The
answer is yeah, you can get pretty darn
close as long as the description of the
character's appearance matches closely.
I've written down the way her skin
looks, the patterns on her face, also
the clothing that she's wearing. When we
go and generate a new video of this
character using text to video, it'll
actually give someone that looks really,
really close.
Control is not the absence of fear. It's
the choice not to let fear decide. We
can render them inside different scenes
as well. We've spent so long guarding
peace that we forgot how heavy peace can
be. The more specific we are in the
prompt in describing the way the
character looks, the more consistent
they'll look in the videos that we
generate. For this prompt of the Sith,
I'm extremely specific in the way that
he looks. He's tall. He's lean. He has
pale white ashy skin and dark veins on
his gaunt face. I also specify the
hairstyle. He has gray hair tied in a
bun, and he wears a raggedy black cloak
with sharp edge plating on the
shoulders. Here's a bunch of videos I
generated of this specific Sith Lord.
The main thing you'll notice that is
kind of different is the shoulder pads
he's wearing. For some of them, they
look like plates. For other ones,
there's some sharp needles pointing out,
but we could have just removed that part
of the prop that talks about the plating
on his shoulders. At this point, I'm
sure you've noticed that Veil 3 also
generates sound effects that go along
with the characters, the lightsabers,
the steps that he's taken as he's
walking. Although, from what I can tell,
you don't actually have that much
control over what specific sound effects
are generated. The amount of voice
control you have is limited to a certain
extent. For example, in this prompt of
the Sith, I specifically said that he
reaches out with his hand and yells no.
I want him to be kind of screeching out
and screaming with a very exaggerated
facial expression. No. Oh,
okay. So, we do hear him screaming a bit
at the end, but the part where he says
no happens at the beginning,
and we don't even see his mouth moving
along with that word. So, for super
super expressive voice control, it
doesn't seem like it's quite there just
yet, but the video animations do look
incredible. If you want to adding the
sounds later in by yourself, these are
8second videos, by the way. There's a
few different options to download, you
can get a GIF, the original size, or
upscale it to high definition. I found
that the upscaler did seem to get stuck
a bunch of times, so maybe it's not
working correctly right now. We can also
add in multiple characters into the same
scene and have them interact with each
other. In this prompt, I copied in the
full description of the female Jedi and
I also copied in the full description of
the Sith. And I have them talking to
each other. So, the male Sith says,
"Tell me Jedi, how many died while you
meditated?" And the female Jedi says,
"And how many screamed while you
searched for meaning in their
suffering?" You can't specifically tell
each character the script that they're
going to be saying inside the video.
Tell me, Jedi, how many died while you
meditated and how many screamed while
you searched for meaning in their
suffering? And using this same
technique, we can create the two of them
interacting together, for example, in a
lightsaber battle.
So, this battle isn't exactly as dynamic
as a real movie. This video clip does
start off a little slow. There's not
that much motion at the start, but as we
get later on into the video and they
start swinging their lightsabers. It's a
pretty epic looking battle. I mean,
there's sparks flying everywhere. The
sound effects also sound realistic to
me. So, what about when it comes to
directing the camera inside the AI
videos? You do have quite a bit of
control over how the camera motion
moves. To start off, let's go with a
shot of a Sith temple. We're going to
prompt for a slow crane shot behind a
cloaked figure walking up the steps to
an ancient Sith temple in Star Wars. The
cameras flies above and slowly tilts
down to reveal the Sith temple. Red
lightning inside a thunderstorm.
So, what happened here? That wasn't
exactly the video that I prompted for.
The Sith is actually walking down the
steps instead of walking up the step
like I asked for inside the prompt. Just
like any other AI image generator or AI
video, there is some randomness in VO3,
which means every time you run the same
prompt, you won't get the same results.
So, sometimes it's a good idea to run
the prompt multiple times. Here's
another video generated of me running
the exact same prompt again. And this
time, we'll see him walking up the steps
like I asked
for. There's some pretty cool camera
movement effects you can create. Here's
an example where I asked for the video
to start with a close-up shot on a
gloved finger hovering over a blaster.
And then the camera is going to tilt up
and reveal a bounty hunter with a helmet
on. This was one of my favorite video
generations. I can't get over how good
this looks. In the prompt, I
specifically told the camera to quickly
tilt up, and you see the movement
flashing from the blaster to the helmet
of the Dante Hunter. Here's more of an
advanced tip. When you prompt for
specific subjects in the video, a lot of
the times that can override the camera
movement and the camera angle that you
ask for. For example, I want to generate
an over theshoulder shot of a rebel
flying inside a spaceship. I want it to
be looking outside the cockpit window
where we can see other fighter jets
flying by. Here's the overthe-shoulder
view that I'm actually looking for. The
camera is placed behind the pilot. We
can see his shoulder and the back of his
head, but we're looking outside the
window. If I run that prompt inside of
V3, though, you'll see that the video
actually starts with a medium body shot
showing the pilot's face and body before
switching to an over-the-shoulder
shot. That's not what I asked for. The
reason is because we included the words
the rebel pilot inside the prompt. And
so Veil 3 wants to show that subject in
the video. However, if I remove that
phrase, rebel pilot, and just say over
the shoulder shot inside a cockpit of a
spaceship, here's what we get. Because I
didn't add the subject of rebel fighter
inside the video, it prioritizes the
camera angle that I'm asking for and
gives me a perfect overthe-shoulder shot
for the entire video. Here's another
clip I generated where I asked her to
start from the feet of stormtroopers
marching through a town and then pan up
to reveal the body and helmets of those
stormtroopers. What are the limitations
of what it can do as far as camera
motion is concerned? If you try to add
in too much movement, the quality of the
videos will degrade. In a prompt, if I
ask for it to start with a shot of a
Star Wars droid making some beeping
noises and then pan towards the Jedi
character that we described earlier,
what's going to happen is that there's
just too much going on inside this
prompt for it to animate it properly.
Let's take a look.
I know, I
know, quit your whining. While the
emotion does look pretty good, the voice
gets mixed up. It doesn't read the words
that I asked her to say properly. I
know. I know. Qui, quit your whining.
Here's another example where I asked for
the Sith to reach out with his palm, say
some words, and then use the force to
send a bounty hunter flying through the
air.
This will be the last time you fail me.
This video doesn't make any sense at
all. It looks like the Sith does some
kind of a 360 flip and then the bounty
hunter appears out of nowhere. So, if
you want to create more dynamic scenes
like this, it's better to animate it in
smaller chunks separately. So, I'll
create a video of the Sith reaching out
with his palm and then a separate one
for the bounty hunter. This will be the
last time you fail me.
Think about the exact textures,
patterns, and materials that you want
inside your videos. Here's a video I
generated of our Jedi earlier, and she's
riding on top of a speeder. But the
chrome metallic silver look on the
speeder, it doesn't fit a Star Wars
movie. So instead, in this prompt, I
specifically told the AI video generator
the textures of the speeder that I want
should be rusty, made out of old metal
scraps, and have some plants growing on
the side of it. And we get a scene
that's much more visually aligned
overall. So far we've covered text to
video, but we can also do frames to
video in which case we upload a
reference image first and then Google
will create a video for us based on that
reference image. You might be thinking
if the text to video is so good, why do
we still need image to video? The reason
is because text to video is limited a
lot of the times in its ability to
generate the specific characters or
scenes you want. For example, this is a
character from Star Wars called Jar Jar
Binks. If you're not familiar with him,
he's basically an alien that looks like
this guy. Kind of a pretty well-known
character. But if I try to generate him
inside Google V3 using only the text
box, it gives me a character that
doesn't look like Jar Jar Binks at all.
Twist in the minds. You are just too
blind to see. And that's where frames to
video comes in. So let's go to frames to
video and we'll have an option to upload
some images. So we can upload our image
or generate an image directly inside 3.
So let's generate an image and enter a
prompt. Jar Binks from Star Wars
as a Sith. He's wearing a black cloak
and holding a red lightsaber cinematic
film.
Then we can run this prompt and create
the images and it'll generate a
character image that looks much much
closer to Jar Jar. We can go ahead and
use this image to generate a video of
it. And inside the prompt, we can ask
for anything. For example, the camera
zooms zooms in as he waves his
lightsaber.
Let's try and generate that and it'll
create a decent looking video from the
reference image that we uploaded. Now,
when it comes to using the image frames
to video feature, I don't recommend it
as much as just trying to use text to
video. So, let me explain. There are
some decent features you can get from
image to video. For example, if we
upload a reference image, let's say
we'll put in this photo of a spaceship.
We do have the option of adding in some
camera movements, but there's a bunch of
options here. You can dialing in on the
character. You can tilt the camera down.
Um, there's a bunch of them. I'm not
sure why they're not all displaying
right now properly, but let's go with
orbiting left around the subject. and
let's put in the prompt the camera
circles around the spaceship. Now, if we
look inside the settings, you can see
that I have selected the Google V3 model
for the video
generation. However, if we try to
actually run this prompt, you'll see
this pop up which says switching you to
a compatible model for this feature.
This is because a lot of the
imagetovideo
features only work with the Ve2 model.
For example, adding in the camera
motions, which means you won't be able
to use the most advanced video model for
this feature. But let's generate it
anyways and see what it looks like. The
camera movements do work pretty well.
The only thing is that, like I said, the
video model isn't going to be the newest
V3 model. Depending on the scene that
you need, I think a lot of these will
work perfectly fine. The camera
movements do look pretty smooth and
follow what you ask
for. But if you want to use camera
motions with the new Veil 3 model,
you'll need to directly add them into
the prompt by yourself. Here's a example
where I told the camera to pull back
while the Jedi walks forward and waves
her white lightsaber.
Here's another example where I prompted
for the camera to circle around the
subject. You do have a decent amount of
control over the camera motion in just
the prompt itself. Here's one of the
camera tilting down while this hunter
jumps down from the
ledge. Circling back to what I said
previously, I do think the text to video
works better than using a reference
image inside Veo 2. So, if possible, try
to create the videos using just the text
prompt if you can. So, I've got this
reference image of the bounty hunter,
and I told him to jump down from the
ledge onto the ground. It's kind of a
smaller hop, not exactly a dynamic jump
from a tall ledge onto the ground. So,
instead, I directly used just a text
prompt where I described the visuals of
the scene. I wanted to start with a
front view of a bounty hunter from Star
Wars. He's wearing a rusty helmet and
rusty armor and the camera tilts down as
he jumps down from a tall ledge into a
rock pit and lands on the ground. It
should be a bright sunlit rocky
environment with brown rocks and some
sand just like the image that I showed
earlier. And let's see what the video
looks
like if we compare it to using a
reference image. The motion is way more
dynamic and I think the sound effects in
general are better.
Also, here's another limitation. If you
use reference images, you can't actually
create the lifelike talking characters.
So, I started with this reference image
of a woman sitting on a jade throne. And
I prompted for her to stand up, pick up
a lightsaber, and say the words, "May
the force be with you." But one problem
with using uh image reference is that
when you try to animate a talking
character, it can make the character
move their mouth around like they're
talking, but they won't actually say the
words you want them to. You do see these
subtitles on the screen. This is
something that they need to fix cuz we
don't need those. However, if you have
an image of a character that you really,
really want to use, for example, this
Asian woman sitting on a jade throne, I
mean, I think this looks really, really
amazing. You can generate the video
inside VA3 and use a lip sync tool on
another platform. Uh so I created this
video of the female Jedi using the image
frames to video. She doesn't say
anything inside here, but we're going to
go to an AI voice generator. I'm using
11 Labs here. And we can enter a speech
that we wanted to say. May the force be
with you. There's a bunch of voices you
can pick from here. I'm selecting Jen.
Then we can generate the AI speech. May
the force be with you. We have the voice
and the video from Google Veil. We can
use a tool like Pix for example which
does have AI lip sync. Hit this speech
button right here. And inside here I've
uploaded the video from Google V3 and
also the audio file we just generated
using 11 Labs. And we can create the lip
sync.
This isn't the ideal solution. I'm sure
Google at some point will update their
Veil 3 model to also allow you to create
talking characters using reference
images, but for now, this is kind of
what you got to do. And this is what our
lipsync character looks like. May the
force be with you. Again, let's try to
replicate this scene using just text to
video. Here's the prompt I'll use. An
Asian female Jedi from Star Wars. She
has two small ram horns on her head and
is wearing a white sleeveless dress with
gold ornaments. She sits on a circular
jade throne in Saturn Asian Palace. She
stands up, pulls out a green lightsaber.
She says, "May the force be with you.
Star Wars cinematic film." I tried to
describe the image I showed earlier as
closely as possible. Let's see what the
video looks like.
May the force be with you.
All right. So, let's be honest here.
That's not a very visually appealing
video. She does stand up and swing the
lightsaber around and say the words I
prompted for exactly, but I don't think
this is a cinematic looking shot. I
mean, the colors, the horns on her head
look kind of weird. And the colors just
look really, really bland. So, when it
comes to writing the text prompts,
sometimes it'll generate a really great
looking video with a small amount of
effort, but sometimes you need to
describe the exact cinematic shot that
you want, including the colors and the
environment. So, let's update this
prompt a little bit. This time, I'm
going to describe the visual look of the
shot a bit more. So, again, we're going
with an Asian female Jedi from Star
Wars. She's wearing a white sleeveless
dress with gold ornaments. She sits on a
glowing dark jade throne inside a dark
Asian palace. She stands up and pulls
out a green lightsaber. Muted dark
colors, high contrast between the dark
green jade throne and the darker palace
with intricate Asian designs and dragon
statues behind the Jedi. Now, if we
generate the video, I think we'll get
something that looks a lot more visually
aesthetic and cinematic.
May the force be with you.
If we compare the two video clips I
generated, I mean, the before and after
is enormous. So, you really need to
describe the visual aesthetic you're
going for inside the prompt more closely
to get the best looking
shots. When you're using image frames to
video, it does also limit your
creativity quite a bit. I'm starting
with this image frame of a woman who's
holding a lightsaber. And in the prompt,
I'm saying the camera pans left and
tilts up to reveal a giant AT&T vehicle
from Star Wars cinematic film. If we
generate this, here's what
happens. Okay, so you see that? You see
how it suddenly switches from the
initial image frame to this like weird
animation of her and like a black AT&T
in the background. But instead, if we
just use the text prompt by itself and
describe the cinematic shot that we
want, a close-up shot on a female Jedi
from Star Wars with a white lightsaber
on a dusty battlefield. The camera pans
left and tilts up to reveal a giant AT&T
vehicle from Star Wars. Dark orange dust
and color toss. If we generate this
without any reference
image, the AT&T robot doesn't look
exactly like it would inside a Star Wars
movie, but you can see that the amount
of creativity that you have and the
control you have over the cinematic
camera movements is way higher when
using just the text prompt.
There is another feature that I think is
worth mentioning inside VO3 and that is
this ingredients to video feature. Now
what this does is let you combine
multiple characters or ingredients
inside the same scene. So for example,
if I go to ingredients to video down
here, I can upload three images inside
the video generator. And so I've got a
couple of different characters. Uh, I
have this this woman with blue skin, got
this guy, uh, a bounty hunter with red
skin, and I'm also going to go with this
landscape image. And in the prompt, we
can go with the woman with blue skin and
the man with red skin walk together on a
rocky landscape. using this image def
feature again. Uh it's not going to let
you use the newest Veil 3 model and
instead it'll force you to use an older
Veo2 model. The quality isn't going to
be as high. Uh it's also not going to
give you the sound effects. This one was
actually particularly bad. So I just ran
this prompt again, except this time at
the end I specifically told it to give
it muted colors. um and also use the
words cinematic film and we get
something that's a bit more reasonable.
So, this is a cool way that you can
create videos with multiple of your own
characters inside of them. Now, the
characters aren't always going to match
your reference images exactly. Um, this
guy with the blue skin doesn't look
quite like the reference image that I
used, but I do think this is worth
mentioning. Now, there are some more
features inside Google Flow. You can use
add to scene inside of a video. And what
this will do is actually let you extend
the video if you want. So, here was a
clip I generated of the woman uh and the
AT&T robot. So, uh we can jump to which
is supposed to generate a different
angle of the scene. It doesn't actually
work that well based on what I've seen.
We can extend the video though. The
camera passed to an army of storm
troopers marching. And again, uh this is
limited to the Veil 2 quality video.
Let's see what the extended clip looks
like. And uh the camera does pan to this
droid army marching behind. So it's
okay. The quality will be a little bit
lower in the extended video um because
it's using a lower quality model, but it
works okay for what it
is. Here's a video clip I generated of
the female Jedi standing up uh wielding
a
lightsaber. And this time, let's try the
jump to feature, which which should give
me a jump cut to a new video clip of the
scene from a different camera angle. So,
The
Jedi walks down the hallway
uh with her green lightsaber. And let's
change this to follow. So we see her
from behind. Now let's generate that and
see what
happens. Okay, so this basically just
extended the video. Um, the jump to
feature is kind of hit or miss.
Sometimes it just extends the video. Um,
but I did also try it on this clip of
the bounty hunter where we pan from his
blaster to his helmet and then I used
the jump to feature to generate him
walking away from a spaceship. So,
sometimes it does work.
So, I got this email from someone asking
me if I could help them create a lawn
1.5 hour AI movie, and they want to
create something epic, like a Braveheart
type of movie. Now, this sounds pretty
cool. So, here's what I responded with.
Oh, wow. For a 1.5 hour film, that's
something you need a team for. I
specialize in creating AI videos, but
you need sound design, maybe voice
actors, cinematographers, video editors.
While AI is very powerful for high
quality work, you still definitely need
people with traditional film making
experience. I actually wrote a longer
email with more details trying to
explain that you don't want to
overestimate what AI can do. And you're
going to love this. Here's the oneliner
response I got. Hi, Veil 3 has all that.
Thank you. So, I was a little irritated
when I first read this because I don't
think this person has experience, you
know, working with AI and film. But, it
got me thinking and I want to know what
you think. Do you agree or do you
disagree with me? Do you think that we
could create a full Star Wars type of
movie using the capabilities that VO3
has? Let me know. I'm really curious to
know what you think. As far as the cost
goes, it is expensive. It's like 125 a
month and then after 3 months that's
going to go up to 250. Now, whether the
cost is worth it, that's up to you. What
do I think? I think nice things cost
money and you pay for the quality that
you get. Now, there's tons of other
awesome AI video generators out there
with awesome features like lip sync,
making longer video clips, things like
that. I did a complete breakdown between
the other best AI video generators that
I've seen and created a same animation
using each of them to see which one is
the best. If you want to see that video,
go watch this tutorial right here.